The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK,
let's get started.
Last time we looked at a
variety of ways to analyze sums
and to find closed-form
expressions for the sums.
And today we're going to
use those methods to solve
a variety of famous problems,
one of them involving center
of mass and stacking blocks.
We saw a version
of that yesterday
in recitation, where you solved
the problem of figuring out
how many L's you need to make
something like this balance
perfectly.
Now in this case I didn't
actually get an integer number
of L's-- which is possible--
because I didn't quite get it
stacked right at the bottom.
So I got 10 and 1/2 L's here.
There's an extra vertical here.
Now in theory there are two
integer ways of doing it.
And you proved that
yesterday in recitation.
So in theory, 10
and 11 should work,
but in practice the
blocks aren't perfect.
I didn't get them
perfectly lined up.
And so 10 wouldn't quite
work, and 11 tended
to pitch it the other way.
And of course in theory, as
long as the center of mass
is just anywhere over this
block, it's going to be stable.
In practice there's air moving
around, and bouncing and stuff.
And so if you're close to
the edge, it's going over.
OK.
So now if you want to build
one of these yourself,
it's not hard to do.
You just start with an
extra block here, all right,
and then you build up.
And that's easy.
And then you notice
when it's about right.
And you can just start
wiggling this block out.
And then it looks pretty
cool at that point.
Actually it was a student
in the class showed me this
a couple of years ago, because
we were doing the blocks.
The next thing we're going
to do-- we were doing that--
and he said, hey,
there's this thing.
And yeah, pretty cool.
So today we're going to
look at a different problem,
and that's the problem of
getting the blocks stacked up
so they go out over the edge of
the table-- if that's doable.
So the goal is to stack
the blocks up like this.
We go farther and farther out.
And the question
we're going to look at
is is it possible-- whoa.
Almost.
Is it possible to get a block
all the way off the table?
That's the question
we're going to look at.
And here I got close.
And you can see it's
getting a little tipsy.
It's not going to go.
It's going to fall over.
So I didn't do it this time.
You're only allowed
one block per level.
So you can't do
anything like this.
That's not allowed.
You can go backwards,
if that helps you.
Well it's got to be
stable on both sides.
But you can go back and forth.
So the question is, can you
get out one block totally
out over the table?
How many people think
it can't be done?
All right.
A few doubters.
More doubters.
How many think it can be done?
Oh, a lot of people
think it can be done.
OK.
Well all right.
How many people think
you can get a block
two blocks out over the table?
A few of you.
How many think you can
get it three blocks out?
You're believers.
OK.
How many people think
I can reach that wall?
Well I got to tell you I
can't reach the wall because--
AUDIENCE: The ceiling
gets in the way.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's going to be hard to do.
But this is what we're
going to try to figure out.
And we're going to do it
with a little competition.
So we're going to have a team
of you go up against the TAs.
And the winner gets
candy to share.
The losing team gets the
infamous 6042 Nerd Pride pocket
protectors.
Very nice.
Shiny plastic.
Has the MIT logo on them.
Very handy.
All right.
So I need four volunteers.
So come on down if
you'd like to volunteer.
You can win some
candy for the class--
or at least win yourself
a pocket protector.
And we'll put the
class over there.
And we get the TAs to come down.
So come on down.
I got a couple of people.
Who else wants to join them?
All right.
Come on down.
We've got a fourth
volunteer out there?
All right.
We got some people coming down.
All right, come on over.
All right.
You got all the blocks you want.
We could even take
this thing down.
So here's your supply.
All right.
Now the TAs have a little
bit of an advantage,
because they've done this
before, some of them.
So you can give some advice
to your colleagues here.
So you got to get some blocks
out of the block supply.
Maybe we should take this down.
It's about to fall over anyway.
So yeah, how do
we get this down?
I'm not sure.
All right, I got this end.
Whoa!
There we go.
[CRASHING BLOCKS]
Oops!
All right.
There we go.
So whoever gets a block
out over the farthest wins.
One block per level.
You can't do two
blocks on a level.
Believe me it's a
lot easier if you can
do multiple blocks per level.
You can go back and forth.
Go ahead and give
them some advice.
They look like they need it.
They're only about half
a block out so far.
How are the TAs doing here?
AUDIENCE: Three steps
forward, two steps back?
Something like that?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
This is an interesting
idea I think
is to go out as far as possible
and then just weight it back.
Does that change anything?
Like this you're saying?
PROFESSOR: All right.
The TAs are getting
scientific here.
AUDIENCE: It need
to be at least half.
PROFESSOR: You know it's
not looking good for you
guys to get the candy today.
I got to tell you.
Ooh.
TAs are close.
AUDIENCE: No, that's too far.
Too far.
Look at the distance
between this and this.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: All right.
Oh, you're about
2/3 of the way over.
We've got one 2/3.
You've got an inch to go.
Yeah.
Maybe it's not doable.
It's not the first
time we've done this
and the problem has
not been solvable.
AUDIENCE: The TAs are
doing pretty well.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
TAs are close.
they're definitely
within an inch.
Maybe an inch and a half.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah, the top
one should do [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You can't hold it.
It's got to stand up by itself.
Now the bottom block can go
out over the edge if you want.
Oh, they're getting close.
Oh, I think you might have
the top block out over.
Maybe.
How are you guys doing?
Not good.
This is trouble for the--
AUDIENCE: It's out.
PROFESSOR: You've got it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Ooh.
All right.
You've got to work fast now
if you're going to beat that.
TAs got it out over the edge.
You see that?
They're out over the edge.
All right.
I think they did it.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
We're going to have a hard
time analyzing that one.
AUDIENCE: Uh, we're-- I
think we're actually there.
PROFESSOR: No.
All right.
Well try another block or
two, and then we'll vote.
See?
AUDIENCE: It's on the edge.
Right there.
PROFESSOR: All right.
AUDIENCE: Looks like
the Stata Center.
PROFESSOR: Yeah that's it.
AUDIENCE: I'm holding it.
PROFESSOR: You're close.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: You're not the most
efficient, that's for sure.
Yeah the TAs are already
munching down here.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Copy
the TAs' solution.
PROFESSOR: Now there's an idea.
All right.
Well I think it's
time for a vote.
But let the class
see what you did.
Yeah you got to
take your hands off.
That's you know.
AUDIENCE: We can.
We're just choosing not to.
PROFESSOR: Get some good
top balancing on there.
I don't know.
All right.
Can you let it go?
They let it go.
Let's see.
Did you get one out?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
This one right here.
PROFESSOR: All right.
We're going to do a vote.
Who thinks they got
the one farthest out?
Oh it's close.
Ah!
Look at that.
We need some glasses out there.
Who thinks the TAs
got it farther out?
AUDIENCE: Boo.
PROFESSOR: Oh man.
All right.
So you guys.
Here you go.
Your very nice
pocket protectors.
A good effort.
There you are.
Well done.
And I'm afraid they
get the candy here.
So you can take these out and
share them with the class.
Oh, leave it that way.
Leave it there.
I mean, we're going
to analyze yours,
because I can't begin
to analyze that.
All right.
Now watching this,
how many people
still think we can get it
all the way to the wall?
Ah, a few people.
In fact, if you stack
this high enough--
and we're going to analyze
how high it has to go--
you could reach the wall.
Now in fact we're going
to find that you probably
got to go out to the
stars to get that high
before you can reach the wall.
So it's not too practical.
Now what I want to do is
analyze this strategy.
And this sort of looks
like a nice design.
They got out there
with just five.
And they did a
particular approach
using what we could call
as the greedy algorithm.
We've seen greedy
algorithms before.
And they used another
greedy algorithm here.
Now what their greedy strategy
did-- and I'm going to redo it
here-- is stack all the
blocks right at the edge.
Line it up here and,
starting at the top,
push it out as
far as you can go.
Now in this case, we can
get it out about halfway,
because the center of mass of
this block is at halfway point.
And that better be
sitting over this block,
or it's going to tip.
So the top block goes out here.
Now I'm going to slide
the top two blocks out
as far as they go.
All right.
That's about the tip.
Then I slide the top three
out as far as they go.
Whoa!
Almost.
Oops.
Theory is always
easier than practice.
And now we do the
top four blocks.
And they did a better
job than I did.
But that's the algorithm,
OK, the greedy algorithm.
The top i blocks-- when i
goes 1 to n-- push it out
as far as you can go.
All right.
And we're going to
analyze that strategy
and see how far it goes.
So we're given n blocks.
And let's say they all have
length 1, to make it easy.
And we're going to define r
sub i to be the amount by which
the i'th block hangs
out over the edge.
and we're going to
count from the top.
All right.
So let's see this on a picture.
So I got the table here.
And then I'm stacking the blocks
out in some way like this.
And with a greedy strategy,
you don't ever go backwards.
All right.
So I'm defining this distance.
This is block one.
This distance here is r 1.
This distance is r 2.
This one is r 3-- and so forth,
until you get down to here.
This is r n, because
this is the n'th block,
and it extends out
r n from the table.
And this is 0 here,
which the table--
we'll consider the table to
be the n plus first block.
So r n plus 1 is 0.
OK.
And so using the strategy--
the greedy strategy--
we want to know what's r 1?
We want to compute that-- if
I keep pushing the blocks out
in a topward fashion
as far as they'll go.
Now the constraint is
the stability constraint
so it won't fall over.
The stability constraint says
that the center of mass--
we'll call it C k--
of the top k blocks
must lie on the k
plus first block.
Otherwise it'll tip over.
And of course the table is
block n plus 1 in this context.
OK.
So if at any point
we've got k blocks,
and their center of
mass is out here,
they'll fall over at that point.
Or if you are
building it this way,
they would fall over that way.
All right.
So for each set of the top
k blocks, the center of mass
has to be on the block below.
And if it is, we're fine.
It won't fall over.
Now for the greedy stacking.
Where is the center
of mass of the top k
blocks in the greedy
stacking, the way
we defined them in terms
of these variables.
What is C k?
All right.
So I got the top k
blocks r k plus 1.
The center of mass of the top
k blocks by the greedy strategy
is right at the edge
of the k'th block.
So if this is a block k here,
then this is r k plus 1.
That's where the
center of mass has
to be of all these
blocks-- the top k blocks.
If it's a little bit more,
it's going to fall over.
If it's less, then
it's not greedy.
We didn't push it out
as far as it could go.
All right.
So for the greedy stacking,
C k is equal to r k plus 1.
And r n plus 1 of course
is the edge of the table.
That's zero.
Any questions so far?
What we're doing?
OK.
All right.
So let's figure out where the
center of mass of the top k
blocks is-- a formula for
that-- a recursive formula.
So to do that we look
at the center of mass
of the k'th block by itself,
and then average it in with
the center of mass of
the top k minus 1 blocks.
OK.
So we're going to set up a
recursion to compute C k.
Where is the center of mass of
the k'th block just by itself?
The center of mass
of the k'th block.
This guy.
Where is its center of mass?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, r
k plus 1 minus 0.5.
Because the center
of mass of this block
is 1/2 from the right edge.
And the right edge
is-- oh, it's r k.
Sorry.
All right?
The top.
Yeah this is.
What?
What did I do here?
Oh, the top k.
Sorry.
This is the k'th block,
the way I had it.
Here's the k'th.
So it is r k minus a half.
That's right.
This is r k plus 1 down here.
All right.
Because the right edge of
the k'th block is at r k,
the center of mass
is 1/2 left of that.
All right.
So we know that the center of
mass of the k'th block is at r
k minus 1/2.
All right.
Now we can compute another
expression for C k.
The center of mass
of the top k blocks
is C k equals-- well there's
k minus 1 block centered
at C k minus 1, because
the center of mass
of the top k minus 1 block's
by definition is C k minus 1.
And they have weight k minus 1.
And then we average that with
a k'th block that has weight 1
at position r k minus 1/2.
And the total weight of
this is k minus 1 here,
and one for this block.
So this equals KC
k minus 1 minus--
let me write it better here.
k minus 1.
C k minus 1 plus R k
minus 1/2 all over k.
All right.
So now we've got an expression--
a recursive expression--
for C k.
And to simplify it, we're
going to plug in that-- C k
as r k plus 1 for
the greedy strategy.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: L is 1.
The length of the blocks is
1, here to make it simpler.
Otherwise it would
have been a half L.
So yesterday we talked
about length L blocks.
Today they're length
1, to be simple.
All right.
So now for the
greedy strategy, I'm
just going to plug
in C k as r k plus 1.
So let's do that.
So I got C k as r k plus
1 equals zero k minus 1.
Well C k minus 1 is just R
k plus R k minus 1/2 over K.
And this simplifies
to k r k minus r k
plus r k-- they cancel--
minus 1/2 over k.
This equals r k minus 1/2.
So getting very simple now.
And I'm just going
to rewrite this
to look at the difference
between r k and r k plus 1.
So r k minus r k plus 1 Oops.
I made a mistake.
That's 1 over 2 k.
Half over k is 1 over 2K.
Any questions about
the math we did?
Interesting.
This is one of those problems
where the math this way
is easy.
There are other ways to
try to solve this problem
and the math gets pretty hairy.
But this one's a
simple approach.
What's the meaning of this?
What's an interpretation
of r k minus r k plus 1?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
This is how much further the
k'th block sticks out over
the k plus first block.
So let's see that.
All right.
So here's r 1.
Here's r 2.
r 1 minus r 2 is the amount by
which the first block sticks
out over the second.
Here's r 2 two minus r 3.
It's that distance.
All right.
So we've gotten a formula for
the greedy strategy of how much
the k'th block sticks out
over the k plus first block.
And it's pretty simple.
All right.
So now we can write
down this expression
for all the values of k.
So what's r 1 minus r 2 going
to be in the greedy strategy?
How much is the top
block sticking out
over the second block
in the greedy strategy?
1/2.
Just plug in k equals 1.
r 2 minus r 3 equals--
AUDIENCE: A quarter.
One quarter.
r 3 minus r 4 is what?
6.
All right.
So now you can start to
see what the TAs did,
how it got smaller
each step going down
all the way to the end here.
You get r n-- the n'th block--
minus the table is 1 over 2 n.
All right.
Now there's a very
easy way to figure out
what r 1 is, which
is what we're after.
How far out is the top block?
What do I do?
Add them all together.
And everything cancels.
So I get r 1 minus r n
plus 1 equals 1/2 plus 1/4
plus 1/6 out to 1 over 2 n.
All right.
So that's just equal to the
sum i equal 1 to n 1 over 2 1.
All right.
Now I got r 1 minus r n plus 1.
But what's r n plus 1?
0.
That's the table.
The table doesn't
hang out over itself.
So in fact r 1 equals a half
of the sum of the inverses
of the first n integers.
OK?
And so now all we have to
do is to compute this sum
to know how far out it is.
In fact, this sum
comes up so often
in mathematics and computer
science, it has a special name.
It's called the harmonic sum.
And the numbers are called
the harmonic numbers.
And in particular, the
n'th harmonic number
is typically denoted
H n just equals
the sum of the n reciprocals.
All right.
So for example, the first
harmonic number is 1.
The second is 1
plus 1/2 equals 3/2.
The third is 3/2 plus
1/3, which is 11/6.
The fourth harmonic
number is that plus 1/4.
22 plus 3/12 is 25/12.
That's sort of an
interesting number,
because it's bigger than 2.
What does that tell us?
Why is that interesting
from this perspective
of what we're doing here?
Now you can get a
block off the table.
Because R1, the distance
that the top block hangs out
off the table, is half
the harmonic number.
Half of H 4 is a little
bit bigger than 1.
Which means with four blocks the
top block can be off the table.
Now the TAs did it using five.
I didn't even get it
to work with five.
In theory it'll work with 12.
You can hang one out
there just a 24th
beyond the edge of
the table in theory.
All right.
If we kept on going,
h of a million--
the millionth harmonic number,
if you were to go compute it,
is 14.3927 and some other stuff.
So if I had a million
blocks stacked up, in theory
how far would I get the
top block off the table?
Seven blocks.
All right.
So that gives you an idea.
You have to do a lot
of work to get seven.
And in fact it's hard,
because the bottom block
would be hanging out one
two millionth of a block.
All right?
So you're adding up
a lot of tiny things
to get to seven out there.
Now it turns out that
the harmonic numbers
grow to infinity.
And we'll see that.
But they grow very, very slowly.
And to see that, we need to
get a closed-form expression
for this sum.
Now does anybody know a
closed-form expression
for the sum of 1 over i?
I don't think so,
because I don't
know anybody who knows that.
In fact it's [? probably ?]
believed that it doesn't exist.
So what do we do to get a
good estimation of that sum?
What do we do?
AUDIENCE: Integration bounds.
PROFESSOR: The
integration bounds.
Yeah.
Because we're not going
to get a closed form.
At least I don't know of
anybody who knows how to do it.
So we'll use the
integration bounds.
And what kind of
function are we summing?
Is it increasing or decreasing?
Decreasing.
Yep.
So we'll use the formula
we did last time.
All right.
And that formula is that the
sum i equals 1 to n of f of i
is, at most, the first
term plus the integral.
And it's at least the last
All right.
In this case we have
f of i as 1 over i.
So the first step is to
compute the integral.
And that's pretty easy.
That's just the natural log
of x evaluated at n and 1.
And that's easy.
That's just the
natural log of n.
So the integral
is very easy here.
And now we actually
can just plug in
and get really good bounds.
Maybe I'll save
that just in case.
OK so plugging in
into the bounds f of n
is 1 over n plus the
integral is log of n
is less than or equal to
the n'th harmonic number.
And it's upper
bounded by f of 1,
which is 1 plus the integral.
All right.
So that's really good.
We got very tight bounds.
And now you can see that
the n'th harmonic number--
how fast is it growing?
If I were to use tilde
notation, what would I write?
As log n.
Yeah.
So this means that h
of n is tilde log of n.
Now this is such an
important function
that people have gone
to a lot of extra work--
which we can't do in this
class-- to really nail down
the value-- get it much closer.
And in fact it's now known
that it's the natural log of n
plus 1 over 2n plus 1 over
12n squared plus epsilon of n
over 120n to the
fourth where for all n
epsilon n is between 0 and 1.
Oop.
And I left one piece out.
Actually there's a constant
term in here-- delta--
that's called Euler's constant.
Delta is called
Euler's constant,
and equals 0.577215664
and some other stuff.
And in fact to this
day people don't
know if this constant is
rational or irrational.
But they know it to a
lot of decimal places.
So basically H n is the log of n
plus some fixed value between 0
and 1-- as we knew
it had to be--
plus even some tail
terms here that
get very small as n gets large.
All right.
So say I wanted to using
this greedy strategy.
How many blocks I would need
to get a block 100 blocks out
over the end of the table.
So I want to go 100 blocks out.
How many blocks do I need
using this strategy, roughly?
What is it?
I think somebody said it.
So I want to get r 1 to be 100.
So I need the harmonic
number to be 200.
And what does this tell me
about n to get this to be 200?
e to the 200.
All right.
So you're going to
need an exponential
in 200 number of blocks, which
now we're past the stars,
all right, to get that many.
All right.
Now we won't prove it in class,
but this strategy-- the TA
greedy strategy-- is optimal.
There is no way to get a block
farther out over the edge.
That said, there is a
second way to get there.
And in the second way, the top
block is not the optimal block.
In the second way, it's the
second block that goes out.
So it looks something like that.
So there's a
counterweight on it.
And in the text, when
you read chapter nine,
you will see the proof
that shows that there's
two solutions that are optimal.
One's a greedy, and
one's this other one
that sort of is mostly the
greedy, except the top couple
of blocks are different.
And it proves that's optimal.
We won't cover that in class.
Now actually in the
literature today people
have been studying how
far a block can go out
if you're allowed to do more
than one block per level,
like one of the
students wanted to do.
So if you're allowed
to have multiple blocks
on the same level, it turns
out you can get much farther
out with n blocks.
And right now it's known
that it's something like n
to the third is how
far you can get out,
which is much better
than log of n.
And so mathematicians have
been studying that problem.
Any questions about
the block stacking?
OK.
All right.
So that's basically it for sums.
I do want to spend a little
time talking about products.
And that may get us back
into sums pretty quick.
The most famous product
out there is n factorial.
And once we get to
counting and probability,
probably every
lecture we're going
to be looking at n factorial
one way or another.
Just comes up all the time.
n factorial is the product
of i equals 1 to n of i.
It's the product of the first
n natural numbers after zero.
Now we'd like to be able to
get a closed-form expression
for this, because factorial
is really not closed form,
because it's hiding this thing.
And if I ask you how big is
n factorial, sort of hard
to say how big it is,
how fast it grows.
Any ideas about how we might
go about doing a product to get
a closed-form expression?
AUDIENCE: If you take a
logarithm of a product,
you get a sum.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, good.
Take the log of it.
Well, let's write that out--
1 times 2 times 3 to n.
That equals the log of
1 plus the log of 2.
Whoops.
All right.
So I've now got a sum.
And now that I've got a sum
we can use all the tools
we had for sums.
So really, products
look hairy, but they're
no different than sums.
Because we're going to
get an approximation
or get an answer for
[? login ?] n factorial.
Then we'll exponentiate it,
and we'll have the answer.
All right.
So we're looking at this sum.
And so how do I get a
closed form for that?
Turns out nobody
knows the closed form.
But we do know a method that
approximates it very well,
which is the integration bounce.
Only in this case, it's
an increasing function.
So let's do that.
OK.
And the formula is easy.
It's basically the same
formula we had there--
that the sum i equals
1 to n of f of i
is at most the n'th
term plus the integral.
And it's at least the first
All right.
Now in this case f
of i is the log of i.
And so we need to compute
the integral of log of x.
And that's easy.
That's x ln of x minus
x evaluated at n and 1.
And that's just n
log of n minus n.
If I plug in 1, I get a 0 here,
and I'm subtracting negative 1
there.
All right.
And so now we'll just plug
this into the integral
and we'll get our bounce.
So f of 1.
What is f of 1 in this case?
Yeah, 0.
Plus n ln n minus
n plus 1 less than
equal to log of n factorial,
less than or equal to f of n
is log of n.
OK.
So to get bounds on
n factorial, we just
exponentiate both sides.
So I take e to this,
gives me-- well, that's
going to give n to the n here.
And this is negative.
That'll be e to the n minus 1.
And here I've got n plus
1 times the log of n.
So it's n to the n plus
1 over the same thing--
e to the n minus 1.
So we got very close bounds.
They're within a factor of
n-- which sounds like a lot,
but compared to how big n
factorial is, not so bad.
Pretty good bounds there.
OK.
So n factorial's about n
over e to the n'th power.
Now this is so important
that-- even more important
than harmonic numbers-- people
have gone to a lot of effort
to get very tight
bounds on n factorial.
So let me tell you
what those are.
It's called Stirling's formula.
And that says that n
factorial equals n over e
to the n'th power times the
square root of 2 pi n times
e to the epsilon n where
epsilon n is between 1 over 12n
plus 1 and 1 over 12n.
So it's epsilon n is
going to 0 as n gets big.
So e to something going
to 0 is going to 1.
All right.
So another way of
looking at this
is you could put a
tilde here, all right,
and ignore that term.
And that's called
Stirling's formula.
This is a good thing to
have on your crib sheet
for the midterm.
So very likely
there'll be something
where you've got to have
some kind of analysis
of n factorial, and to
know how fast it's growing.
Now these bounds you
get here are very tight.
For example, 100
factorial is at least 100
over e to 100 times square
root 200 pi, times e to the 1
over 1,201.
This thing is just really tiny.
This thing here is
1.0008329 and something.
And 100 factorial
is lower-bounded
by the same things, only here
it's e to the 1 over 1,200.
And that is very close
to 1-- 1.00083368.
So the difference
in these bounds
is a tiny fraction of 1%.
So the bound you get
from Stirling's formula
is very, very close
to the right answer.
Any questions on
Stirling's formula?
We won't derive it.
You can derive that in
a graduate math class.
They do that sometimes.
More typically you'll
see it without that e
to the error term.
And you just see n
factorial written
as tilde, and over e to
the n, square root 2 pi n.
All right?
Because that e to the epsilon
n goes to 1 in the limit.
So it sort of disappears when
you go to the tilde notation.
And this in fact is
a lower bound on n
factorial, and very close
to the right answer.
Now this is sort of
an amazing formula.
I mean who would think that
when you look at n factorial
that the expression
would have e and pi
in the expression for it?
Maybe e.
Maybe.
But what's pi doing
in n factorial?
It's sort of a bizarre thing.
OK.
That's it for products.
We're just going to
do the one example,
because really any product just
becomes a sum through the log.
And that makes it really easy.
Any questions on
sums and products?
Because I'm going to totally
change gears now and talk
about more things like tilde.
OK.
So we're going to talk today
and tomorrow in recitation
about asymptotic notation.
It is used all over the
place in computer science.
We've already seen one example,
which is the tilde notation.
And it turns out there's
five more things like that
which we're going to learn what
they are and how they work.
They're used to
explain or describe how
a function grows in the limit.
So for example, we had
the tilde notation.
And we wrote f of x is tilde
g of x if the limit as x goes
to infinity of f over g is 1.
Now the next one--
and most commonly
used one in computer
science-- is
called the O notation,
or the big O.
And it's written like this.
f of x equals O of g of x.
And it means that
the limit as x goes
to infinity of the
absolute value of f
of x over g of x
is convergence--
is less than infinity.
So it's finite, and
it can't diverge.
The interpretation
is that this function
is up to constant factors
upper-bounded by this one,
that this grows the same rate
or slower than this one grows
as x gets large.
Because if f was growing a lot
faster than g in the limit,
then the limit would be
the ratio is infinity.
And we're saying
that doesn't happen.
All right.
I'm not going to do a
lot of examples for this.
In fact, let's go over here.
There's several other ways
you'll see it written.
For example, you'll
see people write
f of x is less
than or equal to O
of g of x, because the
natural interpretation is
f is not growing faster than
g-- sort of upper-bounded by g.
You'll see people write
f of x is O of g of x.
And the formal math way
that people don't use,
but it's the
formally correct one,
is f of x is an
element of O of g of x.
And the interpretation
there is that O of g of x
is a set of functions that
don't grow any faster than g.
And f is one of them.
You can use any of
these and that's fine.
People will know what
you mean, and it'll
be fine for the class.
All right.
Let's see some examples, and see
how to prove a big O relation.
Let f of x be the
function x, and g
of x be the function x squared.
Then in this case
f of x is O of g
of x-- because x doesn't
grow any faster than x
squared as x gets large.
To prove it, we
take the limit as x
goes to infinity of
x over x squared.
That is equal to what?
What is the limit of x over x
squared as x goes to infinity?
0.
And that is less than infinity.
So we proved it.
So if you get asked to prove
f is O of g, what you do
is you take the limit of f
over g as x goes to infinity
and show that it
doesn't diverge.
All right.
Let's do another example.
In this case we'll show
that f is not O of g.
x squared is not O of x.
Of course, x squared
grows faster than x,
but let's see why not.
Well we take the limit
as x goes to infinity
of x squared over x.
And what is that limit?
Infinity.
And so it can't be true
that it's x squared
is O of x, because it has
to be less than infinity.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I missed it.
What's alpha?
PROFESSOR: Infinity.
Sorry.
Infinity.
There we go.
That's important
in the definition.
Yep.
Good.
All right.
What about this?
Is x squared equal O
of a million times x?
Yes?
No?
What do you think?
This looks pretty darn big.
AUDIENCE: It's a constant.
PROFESSOR: That a constant.
So in the limit, as x goes
to infinity, this over that
is infinite.
All right.
So no.
Because the limit of
x goes to infinity
of x squared over 10 to the
sixth x, that equals infinity.
So the thing with
this big O notation
is you just ignore
our constant factors.
They don't do anything.
Just forget about them.
What about this?
Is 10 to the sixth x
equal O of x squared?
Yes.
Because you just
ignore the constant.
That's what the big
O is for, and why
it's used all the time
in computer science.
So yes, that's true.
The proof is very simple.
The limit as x goes to infinity
of 100 x squared-- whoops.
I could even put a square there.
10 to the sixth x squared over
x squared is 10 to the sixth.
That's less than infinity.
In fact, I could take
any quadratic polynomial.
x squared plus 100x plus 10 to
the seventh is O of x squared.
Because smaller order
terms don't matter.
The limit of this here over
that in that case is 1.
So it's less than
infinity as x gets big.
All right let's do a few more.
This really is not so hard.
It's a little dull.
But you've got to
know it for later.
OK.
I could take classes like
6046, and you'll never
see any constants, because
everything is things like big O
and the other notation
we'll talk about.
What about this?
X to the 10th equal
O of e to the x.
Is x to the 10 O of e to the x?
Yeah, it is.
So this is a theorem.
Proof.
Limit as x goes to infinity.
x to the 10 over e to the x.
That equals 0, which is
certainly less than infinity.
All right.
Now the reason this
stuff is useful
when you're doing the
analysis of algorithms
is because when you're
talking about things
like matrix multiplication
algorithms or things like that,
the actual running time
depends on the machine you're
dealing with-- the machine
characteristics-- details
in how you count steps
of the algorithm.
For example, doing
matrix multiplication,
do you count multiply different
than you count plus addition?
And if you start getting
caught up in all those details
you lose the important
fact of the algorithm.
For example, matrix
multiplication--
the elementary algorithm takes
order O of n cubed steps.
And that's the important fact.
And it tells you that if you
double the size of the matrix
the running time will increase
by at most a factor of eight
in the limit as n gets large.
And so you might write
things like the time
to multiply n by n matrices.
You might call that t of n,
and then state that is O of n
cubed.
All right.
And you don't have to
worry about what computer
it's running on,
exactly how you're
counting the details of what
a step is or what time is.
The important thing
is that it's growing
at most as a cubic of
the size of the matrices.
And so in 6046 and 6006
you will spend lots of time
proving that things
are the running time,
or the size is O of some
function of the input size.
All right.
Any questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It gets all dicey if you
do oscillatory things.
And it depends
how you define it.
So we're going to
stay away from that
and just stick with
this definition.
So if this guy
oscillates-- like f
is a sine of x,
sine of x is O of x.
All right.
It doesn't have to converge.
But as long as the ratio
is less than infinity.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Everything you do.
Maybe you'll see sine
functions sometimes.
But everything you
do in algorithms
is going to be
growing monotonically.
Yeah.
Nothing-- no wacky
stuff in math usually.
Any other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
sort of comparing
something that's the same
magnitude that you go off
into infinity.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's upper bounded.
So it's not the same.
We'll get to the
same in a minute.
But it's upper bounded.
f is upper bounded by g
up to a fixed constant
as you go to infinity.
And all constants get
washed away by O. Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Ah, why is this true?
Well technically we'd have
to go back to calculus
and use L'Hopital's rule
or something like that,
because this function
exponential grows a lot faster
than x to the tenth.
So L'Hopital's rule is you
take the derivative of this
over the derivative of that.
Then you'd have x to the
ninth over e to the x.
You do it nine more times.
And you'd get 10
factorial over e to the x.
And that limit is zero.
So that's how you'd actually
do it using L'Hopital's rule.
Yep.
Any polynomial grows slower
than any exponential.
All right.
Let's now do some examples
that can get you screwed up.
What about this one?
Is 4 to the x O to 2 to the x?
Is that true?
No, it's not true.
I mean, the mistake
you might make
is say, oh, 4 and 2,
4 is only double 2.
Big O wipes out
constant factors.
So the answer is yes.
That would be bad.
Better to look at the limit.
So we'll state the correct
theorem-- 4 to the x
is not O of 2 to the x.
And the proof is obtained
by looking at the limit
as x goes to infinity of 4
to the x over 2 to the x.
That is just the limit 4
to the x over 2 to the x
is 2 to the x.
That's infinity.
So the limit is not bounded.
All right?
So it is not big O there.
All right.
Here is one.
Is 10 O of 1?
I've purposely
written it this way.
Yes, it is.
And in fact the
interpretation here
is that you've got
some function f
of x that's just
always equal to 10,
and some function g of x
that's always equal to 1.
And then it is true in this
case that f of x is O of g of x.
All right.
But any constant function is O
of any other constant function.
We're going to revisit
this in a nastier
scenario in a little bit.
OK.
Sometimes you'll see
notation like this.
H of n-- in fact, we
saw this earlier--
is the log of n plus
delta plus O of 1 over n.
When we wrote out the formula
for the n'th harmonic number,
it was log of n plus
Euler's constant plus
something like 1 over n,
constant times 1 over n.
And then some even
smaller terms.
And so people will
write it like this.
And it tells you that the
error terms grow no faster
than a constant times 1 over n.
Technically this is the
wrong way to write it.
But everybody does
it, so you can too.
What it means is this.
H of n minus ln of n minus
delta is O of 1 over n.
All right.
That's the correct
way to write it,
because you're taking the
ratio of this over that.
This is how people will do it.
All right.
So just make sure you
understand that, what it means
when you put it over there.
Same thing with tilde notation.
People will write this-- H of
n is tilde ln of n plus Euler's
constant.
The right way to write it
is Hn minus Euler's constant
is tilde ln of n.
Now can anybody tell me
why this is really not
a good thing to do?
And you think of how
things get really
screwed up if you allow
to start doing this?
Can you think of
anything that--?
What if I did this?
Is this true?
10.
The n'th harmonic
is harmonic number
is tilde of log of n plus 10.
Is that true?
Think about that.
People are shaking their heads.
I mean how can it be true?
Because we know this is.
We know that's what it is.
In fact, this is true.
I can even make it a million.
10 to the sixth here.
It's true.
Because the ratio of this over
that in the limit is what?
1.
And that's all I need for tilde.
All right.
So when I wrote this,
everybody knew what I meant.
But I could write this and be
just as true mathematically.
And so you've got to be
sort of careful about this.
Really, the right
way to do it is this,
because now we're
taking off that term,
and then it's-- actually
I did this wrong.
I should've put the [INAUDIBLE].
Whoops.
I should've done it this way.
Let me rewrite that.
The right way to do it is
H of n-- yeah-- is this.
You put the small
term out over here.
That's the right way.
Because now it's not true
that it's 10 to the sixth out
here-- all right-- for the
ratio of that over this guy.
All right.
So you can do it.
But be careful,
because you might
write wrong things
that technically
would fit the definition.
Same thing with big
O. Same problem there.
Any questions about that?
All right.
Now one thing that people do all
the time that you cannot do is
to use big O as a lower bound.
All right.
So that's one abuse that we
won't-- you'll get marked wrong
for doing that, even though
famous researchers will do it,
and you'll probably even have
a professor do it sometime.
So you may not do this.
f of x is bigger than
or equal to O of g of x.
That is meaningless.
Because the whole point of big
O is that it's an upper bound.
So you can't use it
as a lower bound.
And the reason
you can't do it is
because there is another symbol
to do what you want to do.
And that's called
the omega symbol.
And it's written like this.
It's a capital omega.
And it's if the limit as x goes
to infinity of f of x over g
of x is greater than zero.
OK.
So now we're getting
the lower bound version.
In fact it's just the
opposite of big O.
In fact, we'll state a theorem.
Not hard to prove.
We won't do it.
f of x equals O of g of
x if and only if g of x
equals big omega of f of x.
In other words, f
grows no faster than g
if and only if g grows
at least as fast as f.
One's an upper bound one.
One's a lower bound.
And you've just got to use
the symbol the right way.
Now you can do this.
You can write f of x bigger
than or equal to omega g of x.
That's OK.
All right?
That's all right to do.
All right.
Let's do some examples.
So x squared is omega of x,
because it grows faster than x.
2 to the x is
omega of x squared.
All right.
x over 100 is omega
of 100x plus 25,
because constants don't matter.
x over 100 grows
at least as fast
as 100x does in terms, because
we're measuring the growth.
So constants go away.
If you want to say the
running time of that algorithm
is at least quadratic,
you would write T of n
is omega n squared.
All right.
And that says that the running
time is at least n squared.
Any questions on big omega?
Not too hard once you have
big O. It's just the opposite.
All right the next
symbol is the version
of equality, where you're
bigger-- at least as big
as, and at most as big as.
There's a special
symbol for that.
So in that case we use theta.
And we say that f
of x equals theta
of g of x if the limit
is both bigger than 0
and less than infinity.
All right.
So it's just a shorthand way
of saying big O and big omega.
That's what theta means.
It just both hold true.
All right.
And that's a theorem which
is not hard to prove,
but we won't do it.
f of x equals theta of g
of x if and only f of the x
equals O of g of x and f
of x equals omega g of x.
All right.
So let's do some
examples of theta.
So for example, 10x cubed
minus 20x plus 1 is more easily
written as theta of x cubed--
because the constants don't
matter.
The low order
terms don't matter.
What about this?
Is x over log of x,
is that theta of x?
x over log of x.
Is that theta of x?
People are nodding their heads.
Hmm.
Let's see.
Let's check.
The limit as x goes to
infinity of x over log
of x divided by x.
Well, the x's cancel.
That's the limit as x goes to
infinity of 1 over log of x.
What's that?
0.
Uh-oh.
it is not theta.
I got to be bigger than zero.
In fact, this grows
more slowly than that--
strictly more slowly.
All right.
A little more slowly,
but strictly more slowly.
All right.
If I use for an
algorithm, if you
want to say the algorithm runs
in quadratic time-- namely
at least quadratic time, and
at most quadratic time-- then
you'd say t of n is
theta of n squared.
So let me write that.
So t of n equals theta
n squared means t grows
quadratically in n-- both
upper and lower bound.
OK?
So for these three guys,
to summarize-- sort of you
can keep track of them pretty
simply-- O means less than
or equal.
Omega means greater
than or equal.
Theta means equal up
to constant factors.
Now there's two
more symbols here.
And they correspond very
naturally to this set-up.
What two symbols are missing
from here that would you
naturally add to here?
Yeah.
Less than and greater than.
So less than is little o.
Greater than is little omega.
And less than means it's less
than or equal, but not equal.
And this means greater
than or equal, not equal.
And let me put them up
over here and give you
the formal definitions.
Eraser.
OK.
So little o.
as we have f of x
equals little o of g
x if the limit of f of
x over g of x equals 0.
So f is growing
strictly smaller than g,
so that when I take the
ratio, the limit goes to 0.
And the reverse is little omega.
And we say that f of x is
little omega-- whoops--
of g of x if this is infinity.
Because now f is growing
strictly faster than g,
so I take the limit of the
ratio, and it goes to infinity.
All right so we can do
some simple examples.
Then we're almost done
with all this notation.
What about this one?
x over ln of x-- we just
looked at it-- and x.
What symbol do I put there?
What symbol's missing here?
Little o.
This grows strictly
smaller than that.
If I took the ratio, and I
took the limit, we got 0.
So that's a little o.
OK.
Is this true?
x over 100-- is
that little o of x?
No.
The limit of the
ratio is 1 over 100.
That's bigger than 0.
Constants don't matter.
All right.
So what symbol would go here?
Theta goes here.
Good.
Also big O and big omega.
But theta captures everything.
All right.
What symbol goes here?
x squared equals something x.
What symbol goes there?
Little omega.
It would also be true
to put big omega,
but little omega tells you more.
Because the limit of x squared
over x goes to infinity.
OK.
Any questions
about these things?
So a natural thing on the
midterm is we do some of that,
for example.
All right?
And you'll certainly see
some of that on homework.
You might see some
of that on the test.
You'll certainly see all
this stuff-- little omega
not very often in 6046 and
later algorithms courses.
But all the rest
you'll see there.
Any questions?
All right.
Now I'm going to
show you something
that is sort of scary.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why do
you say that it's
equal to zero when
you said it's less
than [INAUDIBLE] equals sign.
PROFESSOR: Which equals?
AUDIENCE: You said little
omega is less than.
PROFESSOR: Little omega,
it corresponds to a greater
than, which means a
greater than or equal to,
but not an equal to.
And the way we can see that
is looking at the definitions
here in the greater than or
equal to is the big omega.
And that just says
you're bigger than 0.
Ah.
Let's see.
All right.
So I'm bigger than
or equal to is omega.
But I'm not equal
to, which is theta.
So if I know that I'm
this but not that,
the only conclusion is that
I'm infinity in the ratio.
All right?
So that's another
way of saying it.
That's why.
Any other questions?
All right.
Now I'm going to
show you something
that is commonly done, and
that many students will attempt
to do after seeing
this notation,
because the notation
is pretty simple.
Take your limits.
Everything goes fine.
Then you start
cruising along with it.
So now I'm going to show
you how to prove something
that's false using this notation
in a way that people often do.
And the hope is by showing
you, you won't do it.
It will confuse you,
which is why sometimes we
worry about showing you.
But let f of i-- f of n-- equal
the sum i equals 1 to n of i.
Now we all know
what that is, right?
All right.
So I'm going to prove to
you that f of n is O of n.
Now what really-- what
should be here instead of n?
n squared.
So n squared can't be O of n.
So this can't be true.
All right.
Well let's see how we do it.
So the false proof
is by induction on n.
My induction hypothesis is p
of n is going to be that f of n
is O of n.
All right?
That's what we, when we want to
prove something by induction,
typically that's what you do.
Becomes the
induction hypothesis.
Let's look at the base case.
Well f of 1 is 1, and
1 is O of 1 surely.
Right?
Even 10 was O of 1.
OK.
All right.
Now we do the inductive step.
We assume p n is true to
prove that p n plus 1 is true.
Well p n means that
f of n is O of n.
Now I look at f of n plus 1.
That equals the sum of
the first n plus 1 number.
So that will be f
of n plus n plus 1.
The induction hypothesis
says this is O of n.
Clearly this is O of n.
Well I got O of n plus O of n.
That's at most twice O of n.
And constants don't matter.
So that's O of n.
All right.
This should begin
to cause panic.
Is induction wrong?
What's going on with the big O?
You will see this
done all the time.
People would do this
kind of an argument.
Looks pretty good, right?
Can anybody see where
I got off track?
This is a really hard
one to figure out
where things went wrong.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: One of them
might be that you
might be applying O of n
to numbers which really you
really apply asymptotic
notation to functions.
PROFESSOR: Great.
That's a great observation.
Asymptotic notation only
works for functions.
Now here when we
say 1 is O of 1,
well, you could think of it as
f of x being 1-- the function--
and so forth.
So that's OK.
That's a great point.
Now let's figure out using
that how we got in trouble.
We're not quite done yet.
That's a great observation.
But where's the
step that's wrong?
Oh, no.
2 times O of n is O of n.
If I have a function that's f
is O of g, twice f is O of g.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's the end of
n equals 1 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Is it?
So what's the problem now?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well f of n plus
1-- this statement is true,
because f of n plus 1 is the sum
of i equals 1 to n plus 1 of i.
That's 1 plus 2 plus
n plus n plus 1.
And this is f of n.
So that's OK.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
that function.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You know, you're getting closer.
Yeah that's a little
flaky, because I've just
got a single value
saying it's O of one.
But we sort of argued
before that 10 was O of 1.
Now realize a function
behind here that matters.
So you're on the right trail.
But there's an even
bigger whopper hiding.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh yeah.
This is really, really bad.
All right.
So now explain to me why this
is really bad what I did here.
AUDIENCE: You didn't need
the function [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And why isn't-- this
looks like a function.
Why isn't it a function?
It's not.
But it looks like one.
f of n sure looks like one.
Why is it not a function when
it's sitting in this thing?
This P of n, right?
Because I've fixed
the value of n here.
And so this is
now just a scalar.
In fact, you know, I could state
the following-- f of a million,
right, is O of 1, because
this is really some function H
of x that always is this value.
So the difference between
a scalar and a function.
And this is just so nasty
looking, because we see f of n.
That's a function.
But you can never use
big O in a predicate,
all right, because we've
lost the function here.
This is just f
valued at n period.
That single instance is
all that's happened here.
It's not a function anymore.
All right.
If we had f n of x or
something, that might be OK.
But there's no function left.
All right.
So never ever use asymptotic
notation with inductive proofs,
because you will
just invariably stick
big O into your predicate.
And you could prove all sorts of
false things once you do that.
OK?
All right.
Never use asymptotic notation
in induction or predicates.
Thanks.